normally most here that Washington on
the periodic videos see me doing really
bonkers things like setting fire to
chemicals throwing alkali metals into
water but I thought we should come back
to the lab today because just last week
we've had some really really good news
and a really good result for our team
because contrary to popular belief we do
real science too and we've been really
lucky because our one of our articles
was published last week and as you can
see here it's actually featured as a
cover article on on the journal chemical
communications this is a journal from
the Royal Society of Chemistry which has
got quite a good with the steam amongst
chemists this paper highlights some work
which we've been doing for about three
years now and that's trying to measure
what the electrons are doing really near
metals in solution so ions in solution
so there's some big problems there you
see because to measure what the
electrons near the nucleus or the core
electrons are doing you have to use
really really quite complicated
techniques that involve x-rays
particularly things like XPS XPS is a
it's a really really nice technique
called x-ray photoelectron spectroscopy
so we take a sample and we crash x-rays
into it and when it crashes in it emits
lots and lots of electrons these are
called photo electrons and these photo
electrons are like fingerprints for the
chemical species that are at that
surface so if you've got an iron atom it
gives rise to an iron photo electron if
you've got a sodium atom it gives rise
to a sodium photo electron the problem
with XPS and similar techniques is that
when the photo electron comes out from
the surface it has to fly all the way to
the analyzer without bumping into
anything else okay now if we think about
this lab if a photo electron came out of
my hand for instance it would go less
than a millimeter before it bumped into
a molecule of gas so that energy would
change so it would no longer look like a
hand photo electron it might look like
something different so we have to remove
all of the particles from the atmosphere
all of the gases all of the other small
molecules so that we can get what we
call a collision free environment
so that the photoelectron can go from
the sample all the way to the analyzer
now then the problem is that I want to
use XPS to look at metals which are
dissolved in solution now this technique
requires high vacuum so normal solvents
like dichloromethane ether petrol will
evaporate the instant that they go into
our equipment and they then we won't be
able to measure solutions so we had to
use a different technology to allow us
to put a catalytic solution into the XPS
now my group specializes in chemistry
called ionic liquid chemistry's now
ionic liquids are quite unusual because
they're a bit like a solid and they're a
bit like a liquid you can dissolve
things in them but they don't evaporate
so they're like a solid so here is a
sample of an ionic liquid this is a
simple ionic liquid that my group made
and you can see that it flows like a
liquid but it's quite thick and treacly
so we've dissolved catalysts in these
solutions and put them into our machine
so that we can look at the liquid
properties of that metal so that we can
see what happens to that metal in its
core electrons close to the nucleus as
we do chemistry
okay so we've come downstairs now in the
School of Chemistry
and this is the XPS room so essentially
we have to put a sample inside and XPS
as I said uses high vacuum so you can
hear the pump switch is sucking out all
that atmosphere and sucking out all of
that air now we have to put our sample
into this chamber and it goes right in
the middle of this central chamber here
and traditionally you could only put
solids in this type of machine but my
group was one of the first in the world
to put liquids in without having to chop
and butcher around with all of the
instrumentation the reason why we could
do that is because we were looking at
ionic liquids which don't evaporate at
normal temperatures pressures well
that's quite a hotly debated topic but
it's because with an ionic liquid you
have an anion and a cation and they have
very very strong Kalama kinter actions
or ionic charges which pull them closer
and closer together so this actual bond
is very very strong it's very very hard
to evaporate them so the sample goes
into the middle and if you look through
the glass here you can see there's a
sample in and it's a solid sample today
when we did this experiment we put
liquid samples inside the instruments so
that we could look at liquids and
solutes that were dissolved in those
liquids if I put a sample like water in
there or a similar organic solvent it
wouldn't even get into the chamber
because it would evaporate instantly it
evaporate so you couldn't analyze it but
it would also cause significant damage
to the instrument the way this
instrument works is that we put a sample
inside and then we shoot x-rays at that
sample so this is the x-ray gun and
essentially what we do is we take a
stream of electrons which are very very
hot and very very fast and we crash them
into an anode surface okay when it
crashes into that surface it emits
x-rays lots and lots of x-rays of many
many different wavelengths the next
thing we need to do is choose the
wavelength of the x-ray that we want and
we do that by monochrome ating it with a
big crystal and this is the
monochromator so the x-rays go into the
monochrome asian crystal where they
bounce off the crystal surfaces and we
can select a particular wavelength which
we then expose to our sample
so the monochrome ated x-ray is there a
shot down at the sample inside the
chamber where it excites all of those
photo electrons the photo electrons are
then collected by a series of lenses
inside this box where they are
collimated and then thrown into a an
analyzer and that's the big box at the
top and we have to play around with the
electronics in that box so that we can
separate these photo electrons because
of their energy or their fingerprint for
their atom so we collect these electrons
the photo electrons and then we combine
all of the pictures that we generate
into a spectrum and this is this is a
picture of a spectrum which is actually
collecting at the moment and you can see
it's quite a noisy spectrum but you can
see a rather large peak there for the
particular photo electron and that's
what we were trying to investigate when
we looked at iron chemistry so we took
iron 3 and then electrochemically
reduced it to iron 2 and we could see
that we done our chemical reaction
because the position of the binding
energy or the position of the peak moved
significantly and this is the first time
that anyone has ever seen this type of
information using this type of
spectroscopy
I guess the bit that makes this project
different and I suppose a big challenge
is the incorporation of lots of
different areas of knowledge and
expertise the technique itself XPS is
not new it's been around for some 30 or
40 years
electrochemistry is not new an ionic
liquid chemistry's are not new but our
group has taken our knowledge across
these different fields and brought them
together so that we can start to answer
quite significant research challenges